foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Jean
Ross Hello friends this is Pastor John
Ross Pastor Doug is out this evening but
how about an amazing fact the octopus
possesses many astounding abilities that
leaves scientists and nature enthusiasts
in all one of its most incredible
features is its remarkable intelligence
octopuses exhibit problem solving skills
and have shown the ability to learn and
remember tasks even in complex
environments their brains are
proportionately large for their bodies
and are distributed throughout their
arms which gives them a degree of
autonomy and allows for multitasking
their cognitive ability enables them to
employ sophisticated hunting techniques
and even escape from enclosures making
them the Escape artists of the sea
one remarkable example of an octopus's
intelligence comes from an incident
involving an octopus named Inky at the
National Aquarium of New Zealand
in 2016 Inky made headlines around the
world when he carried out an audacious
escape from the aquarium
Inky found a small opening at the top of
his tank and then waited until the
aquarium was quiet and dark before
making his getaway
once outside his glass enclosure Inky
navigated his way to a drain pipe that
led to the nearby ocean and then on to
Freedom leaving just a trail of wet
suction cup marks as evidence of his
daring Escape
now friends just as Inky the octopus
demonstrated remarkable skill in
navigating his Escape so we are called
to use our god-given abilities wisely
and responsibly
wisdom is a gift from God and when we
choose to pursue knowledge and
understanding we align ourselves with
God's purposes for our lives
in the Bible Proverbs chapter 8 verse 10
we read receive my instruction and not
solve and knowledge rather than Choice
gold
and James tells us in James chapter 1
verse 5 if anyone lacks wisdom let him
ask of God who gives to all liberally
without reproach and it shall be given
him
perhaps friend you wondering what God's
will is for your life maybe you are
seeking Heavenly wisdom to know what you
need to do while we have a free gift
that we would like to make available a
book written by Pastor Doug entitled
determining the will of God this is our
free gift to anyone who would call and
ask the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 and ask for the book called
determining the will of God we'll be
happy to send it to you if in the U.S or
in Canada
if you're outside of North America you
can also read it though by going to our
website just
amazingfacts.org.com and you'll be able
to read it for free right there online
at the amazing facts Media Library
and of course this is a live interactive
Bible study so if you have a Bible
related question we'd love to hear from
you this evening the number to call here
in the studio is
800-463-7297 that's 800 God says
800-463-7297 if you have a question
about the Bible or living the Christian
Life this is a good time to pick up your
phone and give us a call well before we
go to the phone lines as we always do we
like to begin with the word of prayer
after all the Bible is God's book so we
need the Holy Spirit the spirit that
inspired the book to begin with to guide
us so let's pray
dear father we are so grateful for the
time that we have to be able to open up
your word and study and Lord as we
always do we ask your spirit to be with
us be with those who are listening Lord
wherever they might be and lead us into
a clearer and a full understanding of
your will of true wisdom found in your
word for we ask us in Jesus name amen
once again friends we want to welcome
you to Bible answers live if you're just
tuning in Pastor Doug is out of town
today but this is a live program so the
number to call here to the studio is
800-463-7297 our first caller that we
have is Jerry listening in Texas Jerry
welcome to the program you're on the air
huh hi Pastor Ross thanks for taking my
call you're alone tonight you got the
best but anyway
um my question tonight uh Pastor Ross is
that how many miles was it from Israel
to the promised land and how long was
the journey supposed to take okay well
good question you know it appears that
from Jerusalem and there's probably
different routes especially back in
Bible times if you think about the
children of Israel and the way they
journeyed about
260 280 miles I think it's 260 uh direct
from Jerusalem to Cairo if if sort of a
straight shot
and if a person walks on average about
20 miles a day that would be
almost two weeks 13 14 days but that's
not taking into consideration what he's
he's bringing with him how fast he can
walk if there's a family traveling if
they're riding by Donkey what animals
they have how long they have to stop
along the way so if one was in a hurry
and you were fit and healthy and you had
enough supplies you could probably do it
I would say
at least back in Bible times probably in
four weeks but that's moving quickly
that's making sure everything's just
right
how about three years I'm building the
sanctuary
how long did it take them to build a
sanctuary yeah because that took a
little time from when they left Egypt
they had to go to Mount Sinai and build
the sanctuary and then go on to the
promised land yes yes absolutely so for
them directly from for the children of
Israel when they left Egypt and they
made their way to the promised land they
were at China for about a year before
coming to the board as the promised land
so almost two years of traveling brought
them the first time to the land of
Canaan and then of course you remember
the story they rebelled against God and
ended up going back into the Wilderness
to finally 40 years later they came back
the second time
thanks so much Pastor Ross all right
thanks Nicole Jerry
our next holiday that we have is Peyton
listening in Virginia Peyton welcome to
the program
hey Pastor Ross thanks so much for
taking my calls absolutely
um my question actually uh revolves the
series of events in Revelation and I was
just wondering if the Bible described a
formal
um judgment for the wicked before their
attack on the New Jerusalem during the
the second Resurrection
yes good question well you're referring
to a passage of scripture that we find
in Revelation chapter 20 Revelation 20
describes an angel coming down from
heaven and has a great chain in his hand
he lays hold of the serpent or the
dragon and binds him for a thousand
years now the dragon there of course is
Satan Satan's bound to the Earth the
bottomless pit is another word just for
this dark desolate broken down planet
and the devil is bound you for a
thousand years the righteous have all
been taken to heaven so at the second
coming of Christ the dead in Christ are
resurrected those who are living are
changed in a moment in the twinkling of
an eye and the righteous are taken to
heaven for a thousand years
so the righteous are in heaven for a
thousand years the devil is on the earth
the devil in these angels all the wicked
are destroyed with the brightness of
Christ coming but at the end of the
Thousand Years during Revelation chapter
21 it speaks about the New Jerusalem
coming down from God out of Heaven all
the redeemed will come in that glorious
City with Christ and according to
Zechariah the Old Testament book it's at
that point that Jesus sets his foot on
the Mount of Olives the Mount of Olives
opens up and forms the Great Valley and
the New Jerusalem comes to rest then the
wicked are all resurrected and you can
read about this in Revelation chapter 20
beginning verse 7 on through nine it
says how that Satan went out and
deceived the nations of the earth and
gathered them together together whose
number is as the sound of the sea and
they went up on the breadth of the earth
and surrounded the camp of the Saints
the Beloved City now the Beloved City
there is the New Jerusalem so you can
kind of picture the scene in your mind
the redeemed or inside the Golden City
with Christ The Wicked are outside the
New Jerusalem they are gathering around
the New Jerusalem but then suddenly
Revelation talks about the great white
Throne judgment Revelation chapter 20.
so as the wicked are about to mount
their attack upon the New Jerusalem
suddenly the attention is grasped by
this scene that they see and that's the
final judgment it's the Judgment of the
wicked now we don't know how long that
judgment is going to take place but at
the end of that judgment Paul says every
knee Bowes and every tongue confesses
that Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory
of the father so even the Devil Himself
overwhelmed by the evidence eventually
acknowledges that God is true
but no sooner does he say that that he
suddenly seems to realize what he's
doing because then he goes around and he
gathers the wicked together
and they actually Mount their attack
upon the New Jerusalem now this
confession isn't a confession of of
sorrowful sin but rather it's the
acknowledgment of the evidence almost
like Judas who said I betrayed innocent
blood when he betrayed Jesus it's not a
genuine conversion so they mount their
attack the wicked Mount their attack
upon the New Jerusalem and then we read
in Malachi 4 verse 3 also in Revelation
chapter 20 that fire comes down and
devours them the wicked are consumed by
that fire so there is a great white
Throne judgment For The Wicked at the
end of the thousand years before they
mount their attack upon the need
Jerusalem
wow did that help Payton oh yes sir
thank you so much gave you a quick
breakdown on Revelation 20. there's a
lot in there you know friends we do have
a study guide that we'll be happy to
send to anyone who wants to learn more
about this 1 000 years of Peace talking
about this Millennial period in
Revelation 20. if you'd like to receive
that all you need to do is call and ask
the number is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
study guide It's called a thousand years
of Peace that's 800
835-6747 Ask for the study guide called
a thousand years of peace next holiday
we have is Brittany listening in
California Brittany you're on Bible
answers live
hey
you're on the air
yeah my my question is how is this occur
how is the Christians supposed to deal
with all these trying times especially
since we're during the
time of Christ's return
okay so how does a Christian deal with
all of these things happening in the
world are you meaning as far as staying
at peace or is it a fearful thing when
we see these things happening what do
you mean or how should we just respond
to natural disasters and increase in
crime and all the rest of it at first
all that wrapped into one basically yes
how are we to deal with it well you know
first of all we need not be afraid Jesus
says um
perfect love cast out fear so if our
hearts are open to the love of God if we
are seeking first him and his kingdom we
need not be afraid of the things that
are happening to us he or the world
around us he promises to be with us and
even if we ourselves have to go through
trials just like Shadrach Meshach and
the Bendigo in the fiery furnace God
promises to be with us and he promises
to ultimately Deliver Us from these
trials and difficulties
but when we see these things happening
in the world what are we to do you know
the Bible says when you see these things
happening lift up your heads
for your salvation draws near so on the
one hand we are sorrowful because we see
suffering we see pain we see death we
see natural disasters
but on the other hand we realize the
Bible says these things must happen God
is allowing the Devil to reveal his true
colors
and God will bring an end to it but as
we see an increase in these natural
disasters let's remember that Jesus is
coming soon we need to lift up our heads
for our Redemption our Salvation is
Drawing Near so don't allow the things
happening in the world around you to
cause you to lose Faith or allow you to
get discouraged keep seeking God make
him first and ask for that peace that
passes understanding and the Lord will
give it to you no we have a book
I will be happy to send to anyone who
calls and asks it's finding peace in a
world of worry that's the name of the
book and I think this will fit in just
with your question Brittany finding
peace in a world of worry to receive the
book just call
800-835-6747 it's
800-835-6747 and again ask for the book
it's called finding peace in a world of
worry we'll be happy to send it to
anyone in the U.S and Canada and you
will be blessed thank you for your call
we've got Gary listening in Illinois
Gary welcome to Bible answers live
thank you in Genesis 1 verses 26 to 28
God gives people dominion over the Earth
is the implication that Earth be good
stewards or just that they have control
over the planet my church wants Jesus to
come again so they don't take a concern
about you know climate change they say
God is in control so what's the
appropriate attitude to have are we to
buy electric cars and put an effort into
it or just watch everything go into
Oblivion oh good question all right so
based upon the verse Genesis chapter 1
verse 26 for those of you who might be
driving in your car and you don't have
your Bibles handy let me read it it says
then God said let us make man in our
image according to our likeness let them
have dominion over the fish of the Sea
of the birds of the air over the cattle
over all the Earth and over every
creeping thing that creeps upon the
Earth so what does it mean that God gave
Dominion to Adam and his descendants
well first of all the Dominion referred
to there is caretaking
nurturing providing and and the work
that Adam did in the Garden of Eden he
was a gardener so he was taking care of
God's creation so as a Christian I think
first and foremost we need to be
responsible at least to the degree that
we can be for our environment uh you
don't want to let you want to be a good
example to others but on a broader scale
the Bible tells us that the Earth is
waxing old like a garment or the Earth
has been inhabited now six thousand
years according to Bible timeline and
it's getting old I mean we just have an
increase of population there are more
stresses upon providing for the masses
yes there are changes happening in our
environment and so you know on the big
picture we want to be responsible
individually but let's also recognize
that the Andy is coming God is going to
have to create a new heavens and a new
Earth so for the Christian our real home
is the earth made new that's why Jesus
said the meek shall inherit the Earth
but having said that we still need to be
responsible to whatever degree we can be
because the Bible tells us that God will
destroy those who destroy the Earth so
those who are Reckless those who don't
take care at least in their ability the
things that God has provided there is a
warning pronounced against them so
there's a balance Gary between being
responsible for what we can can do But
ultimately recognizing that no matter
what we do no matter how many electric
cars we have or no matter how you know
organic we might be or using solar
Powers the real solution for the crisis
our world is in is a new heavens and a
new Earth and that's something that God
will create
all right thanks
all right thanks for your call Gary
appreciate it next color that we have
Judith listening in Nevada junith
welcome to Bible answers live hello
gone hello thanks for taking my call
sure my question is
and about the Jacob's lover in Genesis
28 I believe 10-23 I'd like to to know
your biblical perspective of this matter
because
is this the ladder that is
accessible for Holy guardian angels to
access the The
Throne of God
yeah well of course the the latter that
you're referring to here in Genesis
chapter 28 is a symbol it was a dream
that God gave
um Jacob Jacob was feeling cuddle from
God he felt like his son I am lying to
his father and now he's fleeing for his
life he felt as though that it separated
him from God separated him from Heaven
he was sorrowful he was heavy-hearted
and with genuine repentance he lay down
and God in giving him encouragement
revealed this dream and in the dream he
saw the latter and on the ladder
ascending and descending with angels
meaning that heaven had not forsaken him
there was still a way in which he could
communicate with Heaven God's grace was
still available now Jacob understood the
significance of that because you read
afterwards when he awoke he set the
pillar up it was actually a stone that
he was using for a pulley he set it up
and he anointed that and that became a
memorial that God had promised to be
with him but the significance of the
latter is really brought to view in John
chapter 1 verse 51 and this is Jesus
speaking and he's speaking to Nathanael
and he says most assuredly John 1 51
most assured they are sent to you
Hereafter you shall see Heaven open and
angels of God ascending and descending
upon the son of man
so here Jesus is taking nathanael's mind
back to the story about Jacob and the
latter and in Christ's own words he says
the Angels would be ascending and
descending upon the son of man meaning
that the latter represented Jesus Jesus
is the link between Heaven and Earth
Christ came to give us life to give us
salvation so Jesus is the latter he was
the latter for Jacob he's the latter
still for every true-hearted sincere
seeker of Truth the only way to the
father is through Christ does that help
Judith
thank you very much all right you're
welcome thanks for your call very well
enlightened amen all right we've got
James listening in Michigan James walk
to the program
I pester
oh absolutely yeah no problem
no problem you're welcome
that we always hear about the father of
Noah the son of Methuselah grandson of
Enoch
it says that he lived 777 years and he
died is there any significance to the
777 years I know numbers
our big thing in the Bible
I know the number seven is very
important the number three is very
important here we got seven mentioned
three times in a row yeah good question
now of course we're talking about the
age of an individual so there was a a
literal application there I mean he
really did live 777 years and then he
died but numbers in the Bible yeah
numbers are significant as you say of
course the number seven represents
Perfection or completion and it's
interesting that during uh his life Noah
came and it's you know during the life
of Noah that uh the World Before the
Flood was cleansed by water judgment
came and a new beginning occurred so the
number seven represents Perfection it's
often a number associated with God the
number three in the Bible is interesting
you've got
um the three represents the godhead the
father Son and the Holy Spirit are the
number six in the Bible is often
associated with man and the reason for
that is because Man was created on the
sixth day of the week
and then of course you have the
counterfeit of the trinity in Revelation
when you have the number 666 which is
the mark of the beast it's a man trying
to usurp the place of God that's the
dragon the Beast and the false prophet
those are the the counterfeit uh Trinity
so yeah there is significance to the
number seven specifically here in this
situation you know I think it's just
stating a historical fact that it just
so happened that he lived 777 years but
you can look at other examples
especially in the prophetic books of the
Bible where numbers and Revelation in
particular where numbers have special
significance
Methuselah died the year of the flood
but lameck died five years before then
so I I found that kind of interesting
too and I go
is it significantly that he died when he
was seven seven and so like a year
longer but I might just be reading too
much into this like he said yeah this
was just you're going through through
the genealogies and
just 777 Struck it struck out to me it
is an interesting number yeah but it is
an interesting number specifically for
him though in this context I think first
and foremost the meaning would be
historic it would just be a simple
stating of the fact uh is there a
broader application to the flood coming
and a new beginning possibly but I don't
think that's why the Bible specifically
mentions that that time period of 777
yeah we don't think of Methuselah live
969 years we don't think anything
special about that number yep Adam lived
930 years we don't think anything about
that number if I'm reading this and 777
just jumped out at me so well it's a
good observation the number seven is
significant
Thanks James appreciate your call
next Call of that we have is
um Sherry listening in Missouri is it
Cherry welcome to the program
Pastor how are you doing doing well
thank you and yourself
I'm grateful to get to ask my question
could you please tell me what it means
in the Bible when it says uh Bliss are
the poor in spirits
for those the Kingdom of Heaven
absolutely I'm glad you asked you know
I've actually been studying for my own
personal devotions I've done something a
little different this year I've um I've
decided to read and study
all of the words of Jesus so I started
Matthew and I look for the red letters
those verses in red and I'm just reading
and studying all the words of Jesus not
long ago I actually studied the
Beatitudes you find him here in Matthew
chapter five and Jesus begins by saying
blessed are the poor in spirit for this
is the Kingdom of Heaven to be poor in
spirit is to recognize your spiritual
poverty to recognize that you have need
if a person gets to the point where they
realize that they are spiritually poor
and they need a savior they need help
from God Jesus says this is the Kingdom
of Heaven that's the kind of people
that'll make it into the kingdom of
heaven but those who are proud those who
are spiritually who think they are
spiritually doing well that they don't
need the help of the Holy Spirit they
like the laodicean group that says we
are rich increase with goods and we have
need of nothing but Jesus said you're a
wretched miserable poor blind and naked
so to be poor in spirit is to recognize
our spiritual poverty and to come to
Jesus
the next beatitude is blessed are those
who mourn so not only are we to see our
spiritual poverty but there is a sorrow
for that and we realize we need help and
then it says blessed are those who mourn
they'll be comforted if we come to Jesus
we have our sins forgiven if we confess
our sins he's faithful and just forgive
us to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness that's first John 1 9
and then we are comforted and then it
goes on to talk about hungering and
thirsting for righteousness and then it
talks about being merciful being pure in
heart being a peacemaker so it's really
the steps that we find here in the
Beatitudes or the steps that have to be
taken to draw closer to God but the but
the first begins with being poor in
spirit recognizing our spiritual poverty
thank you thank you very much
all right you're welcome thanks for
calling next caller that we have is Lee
listening in Texas Lee welcome to the
program
yes Pastor thank you for taking my call
today yes
yes my question is I've been reading the
Bible and I came across on a kind of a
strange scripture
yes is self-sacrifice and instant entry
into heaven because in the Scripture it
says love have no grit no man have love
greater than this than someone willing
to lay down his life or his friends that
self-sacrifice that is that is the
ultimate demonstration of self-sacrifice
now specifically here when it says that
it's a reference to Christ who provides
salvation by laying down his life as a
sacrifice but self-sacrifice is
manifesting the spirit of Christ it's a
spirit of kindness and a willingness to
even at personal loss serve others and
help others and of course to be a true
Christian does require a certain degree
of self-sacrifice because the Bible
tells us in Matthew chapter 16 verse 24
it's the words of Jesus he said if
anyone desires to come after me let him
deny himself take up his cross and
follow me so there it is if we want to
be a true follower of Christ it requires
denial of Self in other words we need
need to recognize that by Nature we are
selfish and we need the Holy Spirit to
put the love of God in our hearts Christ
is our great example and when we look at
the life of Jesus he lived to serve he
lived to minister to others and we ought
to pray and say Lord give me that same
Spirit of self-sacrifice that you had
that we can be a blessing and a help to
others around us so yes self-sacrifice
is required now it's not just one act of
self-sacrifice it's living a life of
self-sacrifice it's a lot easier to have
a moment of self-sacrifice and do
something great to help another or even
save another but are we willing to live
a life of self-sacrifice that requires a
lot more work because that's a day by
day experience and that's where we need
the grace of God every day so we'll call
Daily Jesus says daily take up his cross
and follow me and that needs to be our
work and we can only do that by asking
for God's help it is by his grace that
we can live a Victorious Christian Life
well thank you for calling Lee friends
you know of time to take another call
because we're coming up on our
mid-program break and uh The Best is Yet
to Come As Pastor Doug says we will
continue our study of God's word in just
a few moments if uh you will have a
Bible question give us a call we'll be
back in just a few moments
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
Can't Get Enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at
aftv.org at aftv.org you can enjoy video
and audio presentations as well as
printed material all free of charge 24
hours a day seven days a week right from
your computer or mobile device visit
aftv.org
every year forty thousand souls in North
America end their own lives
suicide is a terrible tragedy and while
it's difficult to talk about we need to
face it together as Christians that's
why in my new book choosing life I share
the biblical perspective about suicide
answering some difficult questions about
faith and salvation along the way and
offering practical tips that should help
and encourage others Jesus wants us to
choose an abundant life in him
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8 PM Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
Hello friends and welcome back to Bible
answers live this is Pastor Jean Ross
pasadag is out this evening but this is
a live interactive International Bible
study so if you have a Bible question
our phone line here to the studio is
800-463-7297 that's
800-463-7297 if you don't get through
right away stay online somebody will
answer and we'll queue you up for the
next caller available what are we going
to go to Australia Joanie's listening in
Australia Joan welcome to the program
hello how are you can you hear me we can
yes loud and clear
thank you for taking my call
um in the Bible Old Testament I know
King David jumped in 12 half naked went
dancing for
um our heavenly father I think it was
after a victory
and my question is how do I make
understanding when you're being made to
acknowledge and respect the
representation
or representations of
cultures and tribal dancing
inside the church
okay well good question of course we
live in a world where there are
different cultures and different
traditions and history and as a
Christian what are we to do if uh you
know there is an activity or a tradition
that might run country to what we
believe is a Christian
um well first and foremost we need to
recognize our citizenship is in heaven
and we are seeking after a Heavenly
culture not an Earthly culture having
said that though we want to show respect
to individuals to people whatever their
background and we want to do what we can
that's in harmony with the principles of
the Bible
to recognize them to recognize their
history and their culture
but having said that let's make our
priority first and foremost God you know
a lot of the cultures a lot of the
tribal cultures
when it came to worship and dancing was
a big part of their worship ceremony and
their their tribal Traditions uh they
weren't worshiping the true God often
they were worshiping Pagan deities
sometimes ancestors and so I think we as
a Christian need to be careful in
participating uh in those type of ritual
dances that uh clearly is connected to a
history that is not Christian so you
know it's kind of a fine line and Joan
you got to pray for wisdom on how
exactly to navigate it but you know
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego they stood
up when everyone else bowed down and
there were those who just simply bow to
the golden image because it was
culturally accepted that you bow down to
images but they worship the true God and
they wouldn't compromise their faith and
so we need to pray for wisdom that we
can honor God first and foremost and yet
also respect other groups and other
cultures around us
so thanks for your call John we have
Christopher listening in California
Christopher thank you for the for your
call you're on the program
okay hello good evening pastorals yes
good evening
so I have been struggling for eight
years trying to understand God's word
and I have been praying to God to give
me wisdom and understanding and
knowledge
but he doesn't help me understand God's
word
and due to this I've been failing him
filing and keep falling into sin and I
say to myself why am I still with God if
I keep falling into sin and failing him
I don't want to be a hypocrite so I'm at
my question to you is what should I do
because I'm tired of being a hypocrite
okay and I'm being a false testimony to
the world I'm not reflecting God's life
and I'm just close of literally just
be party from God and going back to the
world well you know what first of all I
I appreciate you calling and you're just
you're honestly crucified you know your
experience is not unique I think
everyone who's
wanted to live a Victorious Christian
Life they've stumbled time and time
again and it's easy to get discouraged
and you begin to wonder well Lord where
are you you know when I really need you
um the Bible says first and foremost
that a righteous man falls seven times
and yet he comes back the Bible says if
we confess our sins is faithful and just
if you give us any cleanse us from all
unrighteousness and sanctification is a
work that God wants to do in us but
here's the key and this is the point I
want to make
it's God that drives Sin from our hearts
oh we can't do it of ourselves we have
fallen we have a fallen sinful nature
it's only a supernatural power of the
Holy Spirit but we have a part to play
and this is key
when Jesus came to the temple in
Jerusalem they were buying and selling
and it was just a chaotic place it was
the presence of Jesus that drove out the
money changes and created the temple
into a place of worship so it is the
spirit of God in our minds and in our
hearts that will drive out Sin from our
lives
how do we get the spirit of God in our
minds here's the key we need to fill our
thoughts
with Jesus with spiritual things
if we spending 95 percent of our day
filling our mind with the things of this
Earth and five percent of our thoughts
with Jesus we're never going to gain the
victory
but if we're spending more and more time
thinking about spiritual things thinking
about Jesus not just in the morning but
throughout the day and as we fill our
minds with spiritual things with
thoughts concerning Christ that enables
God to do something in us that we cannot
do for ourselves and that's the key to
living a Victorious Christian Life it's
the surrender self and even if you don't
feel like it start thinking about
spiritual things start reading the Bible
trying to understand what it says and
just by doing that you're allowing God
to do a work within you so Christopher
don't give up I mean every sincere
believer has struggled with this even
the Apostle Paul says the things that I
don't want to do those are the things I
do a Wretched Man that I am who shall
deliver me from this body of death and
he says but Christ can we need to come
to him every day and submit so I just
want to encourage you all right don't
ever give up for anyone that's listening
no matter what trials or what sins
you're struggling with Christ is able to
give us the victory if we fill our minds
with spiritual truths with his word the
Bible says it's by his promises that we
gain the victory
so Christopher hang in there keep
studying keep reading trusting in God
surrendering to him and he'll do a work
for you that only he can do we've got
Ellen listening in North Carolina Ellen
welcome to the program
thank you so much Pastor Roth my
question is about the site that started
everything between uh Michael Jesus and
Michael the Archangel Jesus and Lucifer
in heaven when he was cast out of heaven
and Authority angels with him question
is was that before God created Adam and
Eve yes or did he show up after Adam and
Eve were already on the earth thank you
so much Pastor yeah good question all
right so the war that took place that
you read about in Revelation chapter 12
verse 7 it says and there was war in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon and the dragon and his
angels fought so we have Michael which
is the prophetic name of Jesus and his
angels fighting against the dragon who
is Satan and Satan was able to see
deceive a third of the angels to join
his Rebellion well this war in heaven
took place before Adam and Eve were
created before the Earth there's the war
in heaven and then the devil and his
angels are cast out of Heaven that's
verse 8 says they did not Prevail nor
was a place found for them in heaven any
longer verse 9 so the Great Dragon was
cast out that old Serpent of all called
the devil and Satan who deceased the
whole world he was cast to the Earth and
his angels were cast out with him so the
war in heaven the devil is cast out of
Heaven at that time he's sort of looking
for a place he can establish as his
kingdom right around that time we don't
know how long after the war but right
around in that time God goes back to his
work of creating and he creates the
earth and the devil sees this brand new
planet that God has just created with
Adam and Eve and he thinks well here's
my opportunity so that's where he came
in the form of a serpent tempted Eve Eve
gave her the fruit to Adam Adam and Eve
fell
and you know the story that came about
so the war in heaven occurred before the
creation we don't know how long maybe
not very long but then Satan came and
once Adam and Eve sinned then the devil
claimed the Earth Is His
and so he refers Jesus referred to the
devil as the prince of this Earth so
Satan claimed it is his thank you Ellen
does that help
all right I think Ellen's off Rebecca in
Michigan Rebecca welcome to the program
hello Pastor Ross hi welcome it's nice
to hear from you I have a question yeah
in your question
Isaiah 43 verses 1 to 2. okay I forgot
that you want to read this yeah let me
read it for those who are listening it
says but now thus saith the Lord who
created your Jacob and he who formed
your Israel fear not for I redeemed you
I have called you by your name you are
mine when you pass through the waters
I'll be with you and through the rivers
they shall not overflow you when you
walk through the fire you shall not be
burned nor shalt the Flames caught you
so what was your question on those
verses I know that there's
there's why are we going to go through
the suffering trial formulation in the
testing we go through why
okay why does God allow suffering to
happen to us well you know if the
Christian was immediately delivered from
all suffering the moment he called out
to Christ there'd probably be a lot of
people that would be claiming to be
Christians for the wrong reason they're
just simply in it for what they can get
out of it but to be a true Christian is
to recognize God's love and to make a
commitment and say Lord I'm willing to
serve you even if I have to go through
the fires it says all through the flood
I will trust in you
uh just like Jesus said not my will thy
will be done so there is a refining
process there is a purifying of our
faith when we go through trials and
difficulties uh ultimately God promises
he will Deliver Us from all of these
things because he's going to make a new
heavens and a new Earth and of course
the righteous the redeemed will be in
heaven with Jesus when he comes a second
time and on the earth made new but until
then yes even though we go through
trials and difficulties the promise that
we have in these verses is that he will
be with us he will go through those
trials with us
so it's not always he's being a
Christian but by trusting in the Lord
not only is our faith being refined but
we're being a testimony to others people
look at our lives they look at the
trials you might be going through and
they say wow she's still trusting in
Jesus despite these things that are
happening to her
meaning that her faith is real and
you're a powerful testimony
you know the time the Christian Church
grew the quickest was when it was facing
persecution and people looked at the
faith of the martyrs and said there is a
faith these people are living for
something meaningful and so trials even
though it's difficult to go through they
can ultimately be not only for our
benefit in the long run but it can be a
positive witness on others
does that help Rebecca yes it does thank
you not not that it's easy but God
promises to be with us you know
specifically here it's interesting
Isaiah in Isaiah 43 Verse 2. he talks
about when you go through the fire you
shall not be burned Isaiah lived about a
hundred and about 100 years before
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego and uh
Daniel and his three friends they knew
they read the writings of of Isaiah and
you wonder if Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego standing on the plane of dura
when nebuchadnezza Commander that
everyone had to Bow Down and Worship the
golden image otherwise they'd be thrown
in the fiery photos I wonder if they
thought of this verse when you go
through the fire I'll be there you will
not be burned of course God was with
them in the fire he delivered them but
they still face trials they were taken
from their home they lost their family
they were prisoners some bad things
happened to them and yet they still
remain faithful and loyal to God and
they were testimony of their faith
thanks for your call Rebecca we've got
David listening in Texas David welcome
to the program
hi
hi David how old are you Rick and a half
six uh all right well I'm glad you cool
David what's your question did Jesus
says just live forever or did he get or
did Mary make him him in his womb from
from God's power
oh good question all right so was Jesus
uh did he live before he came to Mary or
was born of Mary the answer is yes Jesus
was always there he was actually
involved in the creation of the earth uh
Jesus was the one that helped leading
the Old Testament and in the stories
that we read Jesus was there and the
amazing thing about the birth of Jesus
is that Jesus came down from heaven
and miraculously by the spirit of God he
became a little baby in Mary's womb and
he was born and he had to learn just
like we have to learn like when we were
a little child or a baby and we grow so
Jesus had to grow and he had to learn
and yet he was still the Creator he was
still the Son of God even when he was a
little baby wrapped in in cloth and
lying in a Manger he was still the
Creator God so it's a great mystery the
Bible speaks of but no the same Jesus
that was born of Mary was also the
Creator the Jesus in the Old Testament
good question David
we've got Henry listening in New York
Henry welcome to the program
uh yes uh good afternoon
my question is uh
when you when your University recent day
comes to the surprise again
the same clothes that we were buried in
when we come when we come back to the
Grave we still have those same clothes
on okay good question now the answer is
no we won't we will have glorified
bodies and we'll have special clothes
that go along with that glorified body
and the way we know that is because the
Bible tells us that when Christ rose
from the dead his glorified body will be
the same type of glorified body that the
redeemed receive in the resurrection and
when Jesus rose from the dead it talks
about how the disciples ran to the tomb
and they looked in and they saw the
clothes that Christ had been wrapped in
after his death it was still there in
the Tomb so Jesus was clothed with the
robe of glory and light and that'll be
the the garments that the redeem will
wear in the resurrection no need for
cotton Fabrics or polyester but we've
got a glorious robe of light and Glory
that Christ will give the redeemed on
that Resurrection morning thanks for
your call Henry we've got uh let's see
is it Dwayne Dwayne they missed the all
right Dwayne welcome sorry yeah
that's that's perfectly fine Pastor Ross
I always get nervous looking at these
names and I'm saying are they missing a
letter there or is that just the way it
is so all right Dwayne welcome I'm thank
you sir I appreciate your ministry and
uh certainly thank you for taking my
call
uh what is what is exactly does this
mean when it says established Day's
Journey is that a certain distance or
I don't know what to mean when it says
Sabbath day Journey yes now when it says
the Sabbath day Journey you don't find
anything specifically in the Bible that
says you know you can only walk this far
in the Sabbath that was a tradition that
the religious leaders had made and as at
the time of Christ the religious leaders
said they've played they placed even
more importance on their Traditions than
the actual word of God but they'd come
up with a certain distance that was
permissible for a person to walk on the
Sabbath that distance is about two miles
that would have been a Sabbath Day's
Journey now you know Jesus didn't follow
that tradition uh not that we know of
you the religious leads were upset with
him because they didn't follow their
Traditions you don't find it mentioned
anywhere in the Bible that there is a a
limited amount of distance that a person
can walk on the Sabbath but it's about
two miles would be a Sabbath Day's
Journey according to the religious
leaders back in Bible times okay sir
thank you for taking my question all
right great question thank you next
column that we have is Jeremiah
listening in Michigan Jeremiah welcome
to the program
thank you Mr Russ I appreciate you
taking my call
you're welcome thanks for calling
so my question is out of Joshua chapter
6 where the Lord commands Joshua to have
the children of Israel walk around the
city of Jericho
um it appears seven consecutive days and
um it just taken at face value appears
that in doing so they would have broken
the Sabbath
um
it doesn't say what day they started
what day they stopped but it says the
seventh day that they journeyed they
walked around actually seven times which
we don't know what day they started and
stopped um just wondered if you had any
thoughts on that and if there was any
rational reason you know first of all I
don't think the actual attack occurred
on the Sabbath day oh like you say they
could have started on a Tuesday could
have started on a Wednesday they didn't
have to start on a Sunday
um and the reason we we think that they
started some of the time on the Sabbath
they definitely marched around the city
but it was just once it was a solid
March it was an act of worshiping that
they were worshiping God believing that
he was going to give them the victory
but we don't believe the battle occurred
necessarily on the Sabbath and the
reason being is you read in Matthew
where Jesus is talking about the time of
trouble that's going to come upon
Jerusalem and specifically he's talking
to the Christians and he says pray that
your flight be not in Winter neither on
the Sabbath day
well it's a little hard to keep the
Sabbath holy and have a reverent time of
worship or when you fleeing for your
life
well it was not God's will that his
people were to do battle on the Sabbath
either now maybe if they were attacked
yes they could defend themselves but God
initiating this it's it's unlikely that
uh the seventh day there that they
marched around the city fell on the
seventh day of the week meaning it was
the Sabbath it could have been any other
day okay so you feel that um even by
walking marching around at once that uh
they weren't really
profaning the sadness
no they won't now remember of course the
Bible doesn't say anything about a a
limited amount of distance that you can
walk on the Sabbath but this was
specifically given to them by God they
were marching it was a solid March it
was just the sound of the trumpets
everyone was to be quiet they were
marching around the city and they were
doing so as an exercise of Faith
trusting that God is going to bring
Deliverance to them which he did so
there was there was nothing wrong with
that they were following specifically
what God had commanded
okay hey thank you so much all right
thanks Nicole good question
we've got Adrian listening in Kentucky
Adrian welcome to the program
hey Pastor Ross thank you so much for
taking my call you're welcome
and your question
yes sorry it's from uh he is based on
Hebrews 6 4-6
all right um yeah let me read it for
those who might be driving it says 40 is
impossible for those who are once
enlightened and who have tasted the
Heavenly gift and become partakes of the
Holy Spirit and have tasted the good
word of God and the powers of the age to
come if they fall away to renew them
again to repentance since they crucify
again for themselves the Son of God and
put into open shame
so what was your question on that yeah
I'd like to know um because me you know
just being a little personal on this but
you know I came uh I became a
Seventh-Day Adventist about 10 years ago
and I went through a really rough patch
and basically became
um a prodigal and uh this kind of the
scripture kind of throws me off a little
bit because you know I'm you know I
repented and came back to God and it
just you know it just almost seems like
it's saying like look you know you're
sacrificing him again you know so can
you just kind of shed a little light on
this for me yeah absolutely I mean is
there any Christian out there who can
say honestly that you know once they
came to Christ they never fell back into
a form of sin I don't think there's
anybody out there uh every Christian has
stumbled and fallen and we've had to go
many a time to Christ and ask for
forgiveness and God's grace is there if
we confess he's faithful and just to
forgive when it talks about those who
are once enlightened at the taste of the
Heavenly gift and so on and then it says
if they turn away become they've
partakers of the spirit but if they they
turn away they fall away the phrase
there in the falling away isn't just
slipping back into one sin but it's
purposely deliberately turning your back
on God cutting yourself off from God
where you have blocked your mind from
the promptings of the Holy Spirit it is
impossible for that person to be
reconverted because the Bible says it is
the goodness of God that leads you to
repentance
so somebody has hardened their heart to
the point where they don't care they
don't want the Holy Spirit the Holy
Spirit can't reach them any longer they
have committed what we call the
unpardonable sin it's impossible for
them to come back because it's God's
spirit that leads you to repentance but
if somebody has fallen away and the Holy
Spirit has spoken to them and they've
responded to that to that spirit and
they've asked for forgiveness they have
not committed the unpardonable sin the
very fact that they have returned means
that the holy spirit is still getting
through to them
somebody who has committed the
unpardonable son they have no interest
in returning to God they've given you
know they have no interest in spiritual
things they've pretty much given
themselves to the world and the ways of
the world
so you know that's talking about a
unpardonable sin or the falling away
that's what it's referring to not an
occasional falling back into sin does
that make sense Adrian yes yes it does
pastor thank you so much for that all
right thanks for your call we've got
Glenn listening in uh Ohio Glenn walk
with the program
City in the pastor us thank you very
much for taking my call yeah thanks for
calling
a lot of talk about Temple the temple in
heaven the church is the temple the
Third Temple will it be on the mount or
will it be and in my studies I ran
across a very interesting scripture that
I can't find an answer to it's Zechariah
the eighth chapter verse number nine
what Temple is God talking about right
there yeah let me read it that saith the
Lord of hosts the Zechariah 8 9 let your
hands be strong you have been hearing in
these days these words by the mouth of
the prophets who spoke in the day the
foundation was laid for the house of the
Lord of hosts that the temple might be
built now what specific Temple you're
referring to there
yes sir okay well there's a historical
application and then there's also the
the spiritual application when Jerusalem
was destroyed by the Babylonians around
605 BC and they went back and they began
to rebuild the Temple they laid the
corner foundation and at the building of
the temple they were those who looked at
the building and said this is so
inferior to what had been built during
the time of Solomon but the promise was
that the glory of the second house would
be greater than the glory of the first
temple because Christ was going to come
and Christ did come to that second
temple that was built but then Jesus
said destroy this Temple and in three
days I'll raise it up again and that's
really the Messianic application that
this verse is talking about the temple
that Christ built not only is it
referring to his resurrection but it's
talking about the New Testament Church
or the spiritual Temple
which is the body of Believers that is
the temple that Christ has built and he
laid the Chief Cornerstone he is the
Cornerstone and we're these Living
Stones as Paul says put together to form
this this Temple this place of worship
the Bible says no you're not that your
body is the Temple of the Holy Spirit
and so there's a number of temples that
we read about but here in Zechariah it's
really looking forward to the Messianic
if you read the whole context is talking
about the Messianic promise Christ is
coming he's going to build a temple
that'll last forever and that's a
reference to his church
does that outline
okay thank you very much for your call
all right thanks absolutely
thank you for calling well let me see
maybe time for one more caller we've got
Joyce in Florida Joyce we have about a
minute what's your question
yes praise the Lord thank you for taking
my call yeah uh I'm con I'm confused
about
um
uh millennium
the question is uh just win with the
Millennium occur okay let me jump let me
jump in here because we're going to run
out of time the Millennium begins at the
second coming of Christ so when Jesus
comes the second time the dead in Christ
the resurrected the righteous are
changed at a moment in a twinkling of an
eye the dead are on the wicked are
destroyed with the brightness of Christ
coming the righteous are taken to heaven
and that's the start of the one thousand
year period in Revelation 20 also known
as the Millennium now at the end of the
1000 Years the New Jerusalem comes down
Revelation chapter 21 verse 1 and 2 and
the wicked are resurrected for the great
white Throne judgment
and then they mount their attack upon
the New Jerusalem and fire comes down
from God out of heaven and devours them
that's Revelation chapter 20. so take a
look at our study guide called a
thousand years of peace and I'll give
you a lot more information about the
Millennium friends we signing off to
those who on satellite radio but the
rest of you stand by for some Bible
questions
[Music]
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends and welcome back this is
Bible answers live and for those of you
who have stayed around we have about two
minutes or so and we're going to try and
answer some of your email questions that
you've sent to amazing facts so if you'd
like to send us a Bible question you can
just email at balquestions at
amazingfacts.org that's balquestions
amazingfacts.org we've got emails coming
from not only North America but
literally around the world and so let me
try and answer a few of them the first
one is Wesley's asking is eternal
security true or false
well it depends what do you understand
by
eternal security the Bible says if we
are trusting in Jesus day by day placing
our faith in him we have no fear for God
will not allow anyone to pluck us from
his hand uh we are safe but if we
thinking that eternal security is the
result of Me Maybe saying a little
prayer and then for the rest of my life
I can live for the world
and still think that I'm going to make
you to heaven well we're going to be
unfortunately surprised the wrong way
because to have a saving relationship
with Jesus it's a day by day experience
the Apostle Paul says I Die daily so we
can have eternal security if we trusting
in Jesus day by day all right next
question that we have from Ghana Nana
from Ghana is asking when someone had a
previous knowledge of the Bible and
Falls away
is the effort to come back harder and
the answer is yes it can be uh once
we've lost that peace and that joy that
we had in fellowshipping with God we've
turned away but the holy spirit is
convicting us and we want to come back
it's not always that easy to receive
that piece again sometimes there needs
to be sincere prayer and we need to
prayerfully study and read and seek and
long and ask and beg for that peace that
joy that Spirit to come back again so uh
we we don't want to lose that presence
of Jesus it's not always easy to get
back but if the holy spirit is
convicting us that means there is hope
we can come back we can have that peace
uh finally we've got Lance asking in
heaven uh will there be night time
well the Bible says that in the
Jerusalem there is no need of the sun
because the glory of God provides the
light in the New Jerusalem but not only
are we going to be in the New Jerusalem
but the Bible says in Isaiah that we're
actually going to build our own houses
outside of the city and inhabit them
then it says from one month to another
and from one Sabbath to another All
Flesh is going to gather in the New
Jerusalem and worship before God so even
though the glory of God provides light
in the city there will still be the
rotating of the earth we'll still have
day and we'll still have night and we'll
have weeks and we'll even have months
friends thank you for joining us Bible
answers live hopefully you've been
blessed until next week may God be with
you
[Music]
is live honest and accurate answers to
your Bible questions
[Music]